[Music]
alphabet
google's parent company and owner of the
youtube platform is negotiating to build
a technology center in none
other than saudi arabia sounds
incredible but the truth is that since
muhammad bin salman the crown prince
took over this country
has started to change a lot at least
much more than everyone would have
imagined just a few years ago so the
viewer today let's have a look what
exactly is happening
in saudi arabia
[Music]
to understand what's happening in saudi
arabia we need to take a look
at their past to see where everything
began well first of all we
need to bear in mind that we're talking
about a particularly young country here
saudi arabia was formerly born in 1932.
then of course saudi arabia was really
different to how it is today you see
back then many oil deposits hadn't yet
been discovered so it was a very poor
place that still had a sparse
semi-nomadic population
[Music]
basically saudi arabia was still kind of
in the middle ages
well now that i think about it really a
lot of things haven't actually changed
that much
but a few years later in 1938 the first
oil deposits were discovered and since
then
well let's just say that the house of
saud the country's royal house has used
oil to make
arabia look like the united states at
least in terms of aesthetics and leisure
[Music]
so well allow me to explain myself we're
talking for example of cities inspired
by dallas driving american cars
and building huge malls in the middle of
the desert and that's
exactly what they did for decades
but not only that over the years the
saudi government who thanks to oil has
begun to have a lot of money came to a
kind of
agreement with washington that has
lasted more or less
until today so check out this agreement
saudi arabia generates a huge and
relatively cheap oil supply using the
dollar as its basic currency i mean
you've probably heard of petrodollars
and accumulates
all the money it generates in oil sales
in u.s treasury debt
or in the big wall street banks and if
that weren't enough the saudi government
is
always willing to inject millions into
the powerful u.s
arms industry
[Music]
that is lots of oil lots of money and
great business for the u.s
military industry so the question
becomes well in exchange for what
well dear viewer basically for
protection the house of saud bought what
essentially amounts to
insurance from washington to protect it
from foreign enemies
however in 1979 everything changed you
see 1979 was a fundamental year
for arabian countries and for islam
on the one hand the islamic harmony
revolution happened in iran and on the
other hand the soviet union
invaded afghanistan and in saudi arabia
between november 20 and december the 4th
a group of fanatics took over the great
mosque of mecca and accused the house of
saud the saudi monarchy of betraying
islam
and selling their soul to the west
fanatics called for an uprising to
overthrow the royal family and their
debut is where
everything changed the house of saud
leaders feared a revolutionary uprising
and decided to please the extremists the
united states could certainly protect
them from a foreign enemy but it would
be very hard for them to do so in a
popular uprising like the one that
happened in iran
[Music]
so even though this part of the world
wasn't exactly a paradise of freedom
from that moment on things got a lot
lot worse discrimination against women
reached stratospheric levels
the religious guard began an
uncontrolled campaign and
saudi arabia began to finance all kinds
of extremist groups like there was no
tomorrow
both inside and outside of the country
and well that's precisely the saudi
arabia we all know
however just wait a moment because there
was another turning point in 2015
this time thanks to plummeting oil
prices and the arrival of a new king
salman bin abdulaziz it's a great
pleasure
to welcome his majesty king salman
to the oval office this is a king who
decided to give almost all the power to
his son
and now his heir muhammad bin salman of
who we already talked about here on
visualpolitik before
thus a new generation took a hold of the
country my generation was held hostage
by 1979
i know now that my kids will not be
hostages one saudi banker to the new
york times
since then folks a new kind of
revolution has been launched to
modernize the country
we've already talked about this on this
channel but the truth is that the plan
is advancing at full
speed and it's based on three pillars
the fight against corruption
economic change and religious reform so
without further ado
well let's see what's happening point by
point
saudi arabia's anti-corruption crackdown
saudi arabia detaining 11 princes nearly
60 detainees apparently removed were
being told
[Music]
the fight against corruption
the crown prince has said it both
actively and passively corruption
in saudi arabia is a great burden and it
has to end
our country has suffered a lot from
corruption from the 1980s until today
the calculation of our experts is that
roughly 10 of all government spending
was siphoned off by corruption each year
from the top levels to the bottom crown
prince mohammed bin salman
and you know what as it was said so it
was done last november that's 2017
princes businessman ministers
ex-politicians and a huge number of
people were invited to dine with the
king or to meet
with the crown prince of course it's
only in a country like saudi arabia that
we would see
a prison like this this is the
ritz-carlton riyadh
a very very luxurious hotel
of course not everything was comfortable
after all it became a prison that held
such illustrious prisoners as prince
alwaleed bin talal grandson of the
kingdom's own founder known
as the warren buffett of the middle east
this is a prince who according to forbes
magazine has a fortune of almost
18 billion and is one of twitter's
largest shareholders
well not even he even with all his money
managed to escape all the prisoners
were held incommunicado and couldn't
even contact their lawyers
right legal guarantees come on we're in
saudi arabia
[Music]
but what do you think the saudi
government asked for to release them
well nothing less than giving part of
their fortunes and companies
as compensation for all the corruption
that they were involved in
and well here's a question do you know
how much the saudi government raised
with this trick well listen up because
this
is an astounding number it wasn't 1 or 5
or 10 billion but it was approximately
an eye-popping 106 billion
dollars
[Music]
of course a few detractors have accused
the crown prince of carrying out this
campaign not with the intention of
fighting corruption but
with the aim of strengthening his power
and for example seizing control of
foreign-based media yes the detainees
included
important media businessmen but dear
viewer this doesn't
end here not at all
the economic change
[Music]
as we've mentioned on visualpolitik
saudi arabia wants to
emulate dubai and leave their dependence
on oil behind
and they want to do it hand-in-hand with
private capital just as we saw in
google's case
of course on the other hand prince
mohammed bin salman is also very fond of
big pheroic projects the last one he
publicized was neon a macro city
that the radar government wanted to
build in the red sea
next to jordan in egypt
and check out some of these numbers 500
500 billion dollars in public and
private investment in order to urbanize
and build a city that is larger in
area than el salvador this is a 10 000
square mile place that will have its own
laws its own courts and its own
taxes this is a new city that the crown
prince wants to turn into a great
transport hub and a huge international
business center
so basically a much more modern and much
bigger
dubai and this isn't his only project
saudi arabia plans a huge red sea beach
tourism project
the project will cover 50 islands and 34
000 square kilometers
an area bigger than belgium and there's
a few more prince's idea is to get
all these cities to have laws and
standards different from those in the
rest of the country
laws that can attract investors attract
tourists and entrepreneurs the question
is will
radar really be able to make all of
these projects work in a country that is
so
anchored in the past
with news like that it doesn't seem easy
at first but i suppose we'll see so far
people like richard branson certainly
support this strategy
the religious change
lastly there's the religious change the
prince's latest
and great obsession is the struggle
against islam's fundamentalism or its
most radical interpretations you see
saudi arabia is a country of
restrictions which is something we
probably all
know and it may never cease being so
however just a few years ago nobody
could have imagined we'd see
so many changes and quite so quickly
concerts and movies which had been
banned have returned to the country the
religious guard has lost almost all of
its power women can now attend sports
stadiums and since
june they can also drive
[Music]
without going on any further on december
6 2017 the lebanese singer hiba tawaji
starred in saudi arabia's first
all-female concert yes even the audience
was entirely made up of women and this
is something we couldn't even have
imagined
just three years ago listen to this
reflection
we are privileged to be the generation
that has seen the before and the after
the previous generation of saudi women
could never imagine a day when a woman
could drive and the coming generation
will never be able to imagine a day when
a woman couldn't a 30 year old saudi
woman social entrepreneur to the new
york times
the person in charge of this entire
process is muhammad bin
salman
we are restoring islam to its origins
and our biggest tools are the prophet's
practices
at the time of the prophet muhammad
there were musical theaters there was
mixing between men and women there was
respect for christians and jews in
arabia
the first commercial judge in medina was
a woman so if the prophet embraced all
of this
do you mean the prophet was not a muslim
crown prince muhammad bin salman
for a saudi arabian leader to say
something like this
well the only word is wow and by the way
don't think that saudi arabia was always
the place
it was in the past of course it was
always a very very conservative country
too conservative certainly but not the
hell that it became in 1979.
in short as you can see even though
there's still a lot to change things
seem to be on the right track although
of course
there are certainly still dark areas the
qatar blockade failure the yemen war and
the prince's obsession with tehran
iran's supreme leader is the new hitler
of the middle east but we learn from
europe that appeasement doesn't work
we don't want the new hitler and iran to
repeat what happened in europe
in the middle east crown prince mohammed
bin salman yes this prince is a take
charge kind of man but to tell the truth
so far his international attempts have
been
resounding failures as we saw with yemen
another problem is that the arabic
countries economies
are going from bad to worse see in 2017
they suffered their first recession
since 2009
and public deficit is still skyrocketing
growing by more than 50 billion dollars
every year and of course that can make
it hard for the prince
to carry out his plans in any case
having seen this i think we can say that
the oil fall was some of the best news
for everyone especially
for saudi arabian women we are returning
to what we have done before
a country of moderate islam that is open
to all religions and to the world
we will not spend the next 30 years of
our lives dealing with destructive ideas
we will destroy them today we will end
extremism very soon mohammed bin salman
anyway that's how things are but now
it's your turn do you think saudi arabia
will manage to change itself well
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this
survey and i really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for brand new videos
every monday
and thursday also don't forget to check
out our friends at the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]